my feet began to sweat as those two
fluffy little bunnies with the blue
button eyes stared Shapley up at me
here are some things you should know
about a Christmas story that will change
the way you watch it forever which is
significant if you are like me and plan
on rewatching this movie every year
multiple times forever the screenplay is
based on a semi autobiographical stories
of Jean Shepard which were originally
published in the 1960s for Playboy
magazine Jean Shepard is also the
narrator of the film and makes a cameo
appearance here it begins by the way
Peter Billingsley who plays Ralphie kept
laughing during the filming of this
scene because this little girl was
actually terrified of the witch Shepard
actually grew up on Cleveland Street in
Hammond Indiana but the house used in
filming is in Cleveland Ohio and is now
a museum devoted to the film the
grand-prize leg lamp is based on the
knee-high Cola logo the brain has an
exposed leg in stockings to indicate the
correct pronunciation of knee-high Jack
Nicholson was considered for the role
the old man but his fee would have
doubled the budget of the film also
Darren McGavin couldn't be more perfect
Fred gue that must be Italian a suction
tube is hidden in this pole which makes
for the convincing sticking effect Scott
Schwartz who played flick went on to
appear in a number of adult films in the
1990s Farkas is actually Hungarian for
wolf and the music we hear when he
enters is the theme from Prokofiev's
Peter and the wolf
all of Ralphie's nonsensical cursing in
the scene was scripted word-for-word
this kid in goggles was not an actor and
just happened to be in the department
store during filming the director Bob
Clark makes a cameo here thought he was
appropriately weird and decided to put
him in the same way Chris is a Red Ryder
BB gun with a compass in stock in this
thing which tells time the thing which
tells time is an engraved sundial Daisy
never actually made a Red Ryder rifle
that fits these specifications however
they did make a more expensive buck
Jones rifle which did in case you've
never noticed
Bowlings chop-suey is using a bowling
sign here with the W dark down the
actors were not told about the same
waiters prior to the filming of the
scene and Melinda Dillon's who plays the
mother is actually hysterically laughing
here
Ralphie states that he wants a Red Rider
BB gun 28 times throughout the course of
the film
now think about how many times you've
seen this movie and marvel in the fact
that it never gets old
oh my god I shot my eye out you'll shoot
your eye out